Hello.
His name is Jendra. He is a government
servant and he has a question.
Okay.
perspective.
Please explain to me why Islam is a good
religion or better religion from the
perspective of Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam.
>> Our brothers asked a question can can I
explain
why Islam is a good religion from the
perspective of Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam?
The answer can be very long can go into
hours. I will give you the reply from
non-Muslims from non-Muslims perspective
of Mhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
why Islam is a bad religion. If you read
the book
of Michael Hart he wrote a book the 100
most influential human beings in the
world.
The 100 most influential human beings in
the world. right from
whatever history includes Moses and even
the earlier people right till he wrote
the book in I think somewhere close the
1970s
he being a Christian he puts Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam as number one
most influential person in the world
[Applause]
and he writes that many people will be
shocked
and
would be shocked that why I as a
Christian I'm putting Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam number one
and he puts his own Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ peace be upon him as number
three
and Paul as number six and he says even
if I add the influence of both Jesus
Christ peace be upon him and Paul put
together it will no way come close to
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and he continues I select him because he
is not only successful spiritually he's
also successful socially that means in
spiritually only not is he followed but
even socially even in worldly ways and
there are testimony of many people if
you read Thomas Kalile
Thomas Kalile
he's a historian and he writes a book
heroes and hero worship And he says that
if you have to spread something with a
sword, that is the misconception by the
western media. It will do little good if
you pick up a sword and spread it.
You have to actually get the short sword
of intellect. Talking about Hikmah.
And he says that his number one hero
prophet is Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam.
If you read the book written by Jews
Masaman
even he put as number one.
If you read Bernard Shaw
the famous person
he says that
rather than he being called as
antichrist
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam is
the savior of humanity
and the list is wrong.
In the way of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam as a perspective he is the best
living he is the best human being as
example in the world if a Muslim says
that you may disagree these are
non-Muslim intellectuals
and you can give a talk only on what do
the non-Muslims say about prophet Mhamad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and
why does Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
in my lecture if you heard I quoted
several verses of the Quran. Allah says
in surah chapter number 21 verse number
1 and 7
that we have sent thee not but as a
mercy to all the creatures as a mercy to
the whole of humanity as a mercy to all
the worlds. So why is Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam because of
him? Islam is good. Because Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is a mercy to
all the human beings to all the
creatures to all the worlds.
Allah says in surah a chapter 33
verse number 21
that verily
in the conduct of the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him you will find a
beautiful pattern of conduct means
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam is a
beautiful example to follow the best
human example to follow in terms of
being kind in terms of being passionate
in terms of being loving
He even his enemies
though they didn't like him but they
loved him when it came to honesty they
believed he was honest. So when the
enemies left Makkah and they wanted to
keep their valuable with a trusted
person they preferred trusting prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him even though
he was his enemy because they trusted
him. He's an example.
There is no human being on the face of
the earth whose life has been in detail
codified.
If you read the hadith of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam, his full
life has been secured in the hadith.
There is no human being living on the
face of the earth whose life has been
mentioned so much in detail
like the prophet wasallam.
And
he is the last and final messenger of
Mhammad wasallam. So if you hear the
testimony of the non-Muslims and the
vers of the Quran Mhammed sallallahu
alaihi wasallam, it is sufficient for us
to believe that he is the best human
being on the face of the earth. Hope
that answers the question. Brother,
do you believe Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of God? Yes. Mashallah. Do you
believe that there is one God?
Yes.
>> Do you believe that Jesus is God?
>> No.
>> He is messenger.
>> So if you believe that there is only one
God and Prophet Muhammad is a messenger
of God and Prophet Jesus is a messenger
of God. These are the minimum two
criteria required for any human being to
accept Islam. So if you believe there is
no one worthy of worship except one God
and you believe prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of God. So according to me
you're a Muslim.
Brother, would you like to say the
shada?
>> Yes.
>> Mashallah.
So since you believe that there's one
God and you believe Prophet Muhammad is
the messenger of God, I'll say it in
Arabic and then you can repeat it.
Brother, is anyone forcing you to accept
Islam? Uh no.
>> Are you doing it out of your own free
will?
>> Yeah, this is my own free will.
>> Mashallah. Is anyone paying you money?
>> No.
>> Mashallah. So you're doing out of your
own free because in Islam it's not
permitted to force anyone to accept
Islam. So since you're doing out of your
own free will, I'll say in Arabic and
you can repeat it. Yes.
Ashu au Allah. Allah
illallah
illuhammed
>> muhamadan
>> abdu
[Music]
mashallah you're a Muslim
I will say it in Arabic
I I bear witness
I bear witness
Can you repeat this? I
>> This is the translation of what you
said.
>> I bear witness
>> that
>> there is no God
>> but Allah
>> and Prophet Muhammad
>> is the messenger
>> and servant
>> of Allah
>> mashallah.
[Applause]
I'd like to mention brother your that
our beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that anyone who accept
Islam all his past sins are forgiven the
good deeds what you did in the past will
remain but all your sins are forgiven
and I pray to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
that may you guide may guide you further
to help you to get your friends and your
family to the fold of Islam and I pray
to Allah subhana wa ta'ala that may he
grant you ja and give you the best in
this world and
may Allah reward you. I would like that
the Muslim organizations here should be
in touch with the brother and if he has
any query, any questions, any
difficulty, they should help him.